AND I CANNOT -- AND THAT'S TRUE.
BECAUSE EVERYDAY FOR SOME PEOPLE
THIS DAY IS NOT GOOD.
FOR SOME PEOPLE, THIS DAY IS THE
LAST ONE.
I SPEAK TODAY NOW ABOUT MY
CITIZEN, CITIZENS OF UKRAINE,
WHO ARE DEFENDING BY PAYING THE
ULTIMATE PRICE, THEY DEFENDING
FREEDOM.
I'M VERY HAPPY THAT WHAT I'VE
SEEN HERE NOW AND HEARD HERE
NOW, I'M VERY GLAD TO SENSE THIS
MOOD.
THE UNITED, UNIFYING MOOD.
I'M HAPPY THAT WE HAVE UNIFIED
TODAY, ALL OF YOU, ALL THE
COUNTRIES OF THE EUROPEAN UNION,
BUT I DID NOT KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE PRICE THEY WILL HAVE TO PAY.
AND THIS IS A TRAGEDY FOR ME,
IT'S A TRAGEDY FOR EVERY
UKRAINIAN.
TRAGEDY FOR OUR STATE.
I MEAN, THIS HIGH PRICE, VERY
HIGH PRICE.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
KILLED.
TWO REVOLUTIONS, ONE WAR.
AND FIVE DAYS OF FULL SCALE
INVASION OF THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT -- I DON'T
READ OFF THE PAPER, OFF THE
SHEET.
BECAUSE PAPER PHASE IN THE LIFE
OF MY COUNTRY HAS ENDED.
WE ARE DEALING WITH REALITY.
WE'RE DEALING WITH PEOPLE IN
REAL LIFE, YOU KNOW?
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE TODAY
WE'RE GIVING LIVES FOR VALUES,
FOR RIGHTS, FOR FREEDOM FOR THE
DESIRE TO BE EQUAL AS MUCH AS
YOU ARE.
WE ARE GIVING AWAY OUR BEST
PEOPLE, THE STRONGEST ONES, THE
MOST VALUABLE ONES.
UKRAINIANS ARE INCREDIBLE.
VERY OFTEN WE LOVE TO SAY WE
WILL WIN OVER EVERYONE.
AND I'M VERY HAPPY THAT YOU ARE
NOT ONLY TALKING ABOUT IT, BUT
YOU CAN SEE THAT.
AND WE INDEED, WE WILL OVERCOME
EVERYONE.
AND I'M SURE, I'M CONVINCED,
THERE IS AN EXPRESSION,
UKRAINIAN, CHOICE.
EUROPEAN CHOICE OF UKRAINE,
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE STRIVING FOR,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
AND WE WENT TO.
SO, I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR THAT
FROM YOU TO US, WE COULD HEAR
THAT UKRAINIAN CHOICE FOR EUROPE
FROM YOU.
I HAVE HAD SOME TIME OFF HERE
BECAUSE WE HAVE BREAKS BETWEEN
THE MISSILE STRIKES.
AND BOMBARDMENTS.
AND THIS MORNING WAS A VERY
TRAGIC ONE FOR US.
TWO CRUISE MISSILES HIT KHARKIV,
THE CITY, WHICH IS LOCATED TO
THE BORDERS OF THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
THERE WERE ALWAYS MANY RUSSIANS
THERE.
AND THEY WERE ALWAYS FRIENDLY.
THERE WERE WARM RELATIONS THERE.
MORE THAN 20 UNIVERSITIES ARE
THERE.
IT'S THE CITY THAT HAS THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF UNIVERSITIES
IN OUR COUNTRY.
THE YOUTH IS BRIGHT, SMART
THERE.
THE PEOPLE WHO GATHERED THERE
ALL THE TIME AND WAS GATHERING
THERE ALL THE TIME, FOR
CELEBRATING FOR ALL
CELEBRATIONS, IN THE LARGEST
SQUARE IN OUR COUNTRY.
THE FREEDOM SQUARE AND THIS IS
THE LARGEST SQUARE IN EUROPE.
AND THAT'S TRUE.
THIS IS CALLED THE FREEDOM
SQUARE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THIS MORNING,
TWO CRUISE MISSILES HIT THIS
FREEDOM SQUARE, DOZENS OF KILLED
ONES.
THIS IS THE PRICE OF FREEDOM.
WE'RE FIGHTING.
JUST FOR OUR LAND.
AND FOR OUR FREEDOM.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT ALL S
CITIZENS IN OUR COUNTRY ARE
BLOCKED.
NOBODY IS GOING TO ENTER AND
INTERVENE WITH OUR FREEDOM AND
COUNTRY.
AND BELIEVE YOU ME, EVERY SQUARE
OF TODAY, NO MATTER WHAT IT'S
CALLED, IS GOING TO BE CALLED
TODAY FREEDOM SQUARE.
IN EVERY CITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
NOBODY IS GOING TO BREAK US.
WE'RE STRONG.
WE'RE UKRAINIANS.
WE HAVE A DESIRE TO SEE OUR
CHILDREN ALIVE.
I THINK IT'S A FAIR ONE.
YESTERDAY 16 CHILDREN WERE
KILLED.
AGAIN AND AGAIN PRESIDENT PUTIN
IS GOING TO SAY THAT IS SOME
KIND OF OPERATION AND WE'RE
HITTING A MILITARY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHERE ARE OUR CHILDREN?
WHAT KIND OF MILITARY FACTORIES
DO THEY WORK AT?
WHAT TANKS ARE THEY GOING WITH
OR LAUNCHING CRUISE MISSILES?
HE KILLED 16 PEOPLE JUST
YESTERDAY.
OUR PEOPLE ARE VERY MUCH
MOTIVATED, VERY MUCH SO.
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR OUR RIGHTS,
FOR OUR FREEDOMS, FOR OUR LIFE.
AND NOW WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
SURVIVAL.
AND THIS IS THE HIGHEST OF OUR
MOTIVATION.
BUT, WE ARE FIGHTING ALSO TO BE
EQUAL MEMBERS OF EUROPE.
I BELIEVE THAT TODAY WE ARE
SHOWING EVERYBODY THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE ARE.
THE EUROPEAN UNION IS GOING TO
BE MUCH STRONGER WITH US, THAT'S
FOR SURE.
WITHOUT YOU, UKRAINE, IS GOING
TO BE LONELY, LONESOME.
WE HAVE PROVEN OUR STRENGTHS.
WE HAVE PROVEN THAT AS AT A
MINIMUM WE ARE EXACTLY THE SAME
AS YOU ARE.
SO, DO PROVE THAT YOU ARE WITH
US.
DO PROVE THAT YOU WILL NOT LET
US GO.
DO PROVE THAT YOU INDEED ARE
EUROPEANS AND THEN LIFE WILL WIN
OVER DEATH AND LIGHT WILL WIN
OVER DARKNESS.
GLORY BE TO UKRAINE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ APPLAUSE